bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 78
sport numéro 37 allez c'est parti pour
un nouveau tour de l'ctu sport du
département en 26 minutes c'est notre
débat de la semaine la mise en place de
la taxe à 75 % sur les clubs
professionnel peut-elle mettre en danger
le football amateur nous en discuterons
avec nos invités nous partirons à la
découverte de la nouvelle pépite du
triathlon français il s'appelle Alan
Brachet et à 15 ans ce cquantinois raflé
tous les titres de champion de France et
du monde en l'espace de quelques mois
nous reviendrons sur le derby de basket
de national une féminine entre l'entente
le chînet Versailles et Franconville qui
a vu la victoire des valdoisiennes
leader de la pooule évidemment en fin
d'émission tous les résultats du weekend
mais tout d'abord place à notre page
spéciale
football
après avoir menacé de faire grève le le
30 novembre prochain les présidents de
club de football professionnel ont
décidé de repousser hein cette journée
blanche on l'a vu il y a quelques jours
pour faire simple cette taxe coûterait
44 millions d'euros au club
professionnel et concernerait 114
joueurs et pour en débattre de ce thème
qui touche aussi le le football amateur
on va voir cela dans dans quelques
minutes trois personnalités importantes
he desines du football ivinois Mustapha
Larbaoui le président de l'Étoile
Sportive de bonsoir bonsoir à vous vous
êtes accompagné de deux Philippes PhIP
Bunel et Philippe Libot respectivement
président des féminines de Montini et
secrétaire de l'OSC etlancour bonsoir à
tous les deux bonsoir bonsoir tout
d'abord un petit un petit tour de table
rapide vous êtes pour ou contre cette
taxe à 75 % Mustapha la réponse pour
compte c'est un peu compliqué
globalement globalement je peux
comprendre maintenant c'est vrai que ça
a des conséquences et c'est vrai que ça
a des répercussions c'est pas c'est pas
une histoire de d'être pour contre euh
je pense que ça doit être pour le coup
murement réfléchi tout de même voilà de
votre côté à Montini Philippe ouais pas
pas d'avis tranché en fin de compte
c'est pas vraiment le sujet de
discussion au club en ce moment ça nous
dépasse un peu mais bon effectivement si
c'est a des incidces sur le petit club
le le combat des petits clubs au
quotidien c'est pas celui-là quoi je
veux dire c'est on les connaît tous on
on a tous les mêmes problèmes donc c'est
peut-être un problème de club riche à en
courour la vie est aussi euh à peu près
du la vie mitigée oui parce que bah
voilà ça ça nous paraît un petit peu
loin et bon faudrait pas que ça apporte
un appauvrissement du du football mais
sinon euh pas d'avis pour le moment et
c'est vrai que nos nos préoccupations
sont plutôt ailleurs que que sur cette
taxe à 75 %. j'allaisir l'
l'apauvrissement du football pourrait
avoir une conséquence sur le le foot
amateur puisque si euh les clubs de
football professionnel sont moins riches
tout simplement les subvention versé au
foot amateur pourrait être aussi du coup
diminué ça pourrait vous toucher
directement ces subventions là ou pas
alors ça ça pourrait un ça pourrait nous
toucher de ça nous touche déjà parce
qu'après tout comme le disait mon ami
Philippe c'est un problème de riche
alors que nous gérons des problèmes de
pauvres donc finalement ça pourrait
appauvrir les pauvres je tiens quand
même à signaler que par rapport au titre
que vous avez évoqué la mort du football
amateur il y aura mais de mort dans le
football amateur parce qu'après tout on
est tous si on devait mettre bout à bout
euh le temps euh de tous les
bénévoles on mettrait bout à bout tous
ces temps et si on
pouvait donner une
valeur pour le coup une valeur
financière à à toute cette implication
des uns et des autres ça dépasserait de
loin le montant même de tous les
professionnels et des salaires mis bout
àabout donc ça sera jamais mort parce
qu'on sera toujours là cela étant moins
de moyens c'est clair et puis je pense
qu'ils trouveront ils trouveront à mon
avis les méthodes pour que au
sommet ayant la main sur la caisse ils
puissent trouver des solutions en
interne et entre eux pour ce qui nous
concerne on a toujours su faire sans
l'argent on a toujours su faire avec nos
bénévoles avec les moyens du bord on
continuera seulétant c'est pas ce qu'on
souhaite une toute petite anecdote des
clubs comme les nôtres ici présents nous
formons des jeunes il y a des jeunes qui
finissent dans des clubs des clubs
professionnels on arrive même pas à
récupérer des sommes de de l'ordre de 3
4000 € qui sont incluses dans des
mécanismes de solidarité auprès des
clubs sportifs et ça c'était bien avant
les taxations des 75 % encore une fois
c'est très compliqué c'est 75 % d'un
certain montant à partir d'un certain
niveau et cetera mais c'est pour vous
dire que jusqu'à maintenant nous petit
club non seulement les touche pas mais
en plus on doit se battre pour les
récupérer pour des petites sommes donc
croyez-moi que l'appauvrissement ça sera
c'est un sujet c'est pas notre
préoccupation majeure oui pour être un
peu plus clair pour le téléspectateur
vous parliez de ces indemnités de
transfer en fait quand un un joueur est
formé par exemple à trappe Montini ou el
encour et qu'il est transféré vers un
club professionnel le club formateur
touche une indemnité et c'est vrai que
c'est le combat aussi c'est ça concerne
peut-être Montini vous qui dit qui jouez
déjà en championnat de France ça vous
est déjà arrivé de lutter pour récupérer
des indemnités comme ça euh non ma
connaissance non parce que je je pense
pas que ça si ça marche dans le football
féminin parce que moi je pe du football
féminin mais effectivement c'est notre
combat de tous les jours c'est nos
bénévoles parce que là il va falloir que
les instances penche un peu sur le
problème que on perd on perd de plus en
plus de bévoles je prends l'exemple du
club de Montini près 650 700 licenciés
euh si membres au comité
directeurs moi je suis président du
football finin je gère le budget du du
football fin qui est de 55000 € de de
des petites jusqu'au grandes au niveau
national mais en plus je m'occupe de
l'équipe équipement donc on est 6 à
travailler pour 700 donc je pense bon
après comité directeur comité de
direction vous l'appeler comme on veut
il va falloir que les jeunes aussi les
jeunes les jeunes comprennent que bah va
falloir s'investir parce que
effectivement il y aura jamais de mort
de football amateur parce que ça a
commencé nos anciens sont là pour n pour
le dire mais effectivement on est
toujours à la recherche de partenaires
alors maintenant on parle plus de
sponsors on parle de partenair parce que
il faut les intégrer à la politique du
club oui mais avec un un football
professionnel moins attrac peut-être si
une taxe vient toucher les les clubs de
Ligue 1 Ligue 2 qui seraient en en
difficulté financière parce que par
exemple Lyon sur le dernier exercice ça
a eu un déficite de 13 13 à 15 millions
d'euros est-ce que ça va pas non plus
derrière répercuter tout cela sur les
les sponsors qui vont se dire ah il y a
des clubs qui sont en difficultés
financières on va pas aller injectcter
de l'argent en tous les cas ça pourra
servir de prétexte c'estàdire que moi je
suis convaincu que si on veut on peut il
y a suffisamment d'argent au sommet à
lire tous les sondages il y en a même
trop et je crois que d'ailleurs tous les
français et tous les téléspectateurs
l'entendent comme ça il y en a même trop
d'ailleurs le trop étant l'ennemi du
bien on voit bien en équipe de France
que ça peut ce que ça peut occasionner
aussi le trop d'argent donc quand on
veut se donner les moyens on peut je
pense que ça pourrait être
éventuellement un prétexte pour ne pas
faire
redescendre à la base mais le vrai sujet
pour nous c'est de faire en sorte que
nos équipes et nos bénévoles oui soient
vraiment sur le terrain et quen cl c'est
clair on est toujours à la recherche de
bénévoles et de personnes qui doivent
s'impliquer et qui voudrait bien
s'appliquer dans les clubs et c'est de
plus en plus difficile et on on le sent
sur bah des catégories de jeunes
maintenant alors que c'était des des
problèmes qu'on avait sur des catégories
plus plus adultes et maintenant ça
descend jusqu'à des catégories et c'est
ça le problème fa alors pour trouver le
moyen de trouver d'avoir des partenaires
donc faire de faire du porte à porte et
pareil il faut du temps et on peut pas
s'occuper à la fois des équipes et de la
recherche de part ire et ça c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment le souci de je
pense de de beaucoup de clubs et c'est
vrai que bah ça serait bien que si l'ENT
l'argent du sommet pouvait aussi
redescendre oui ce serait ce serait bien
oui ce serait bien par que je pense que
nous bon on parle de la Fédération la
Fédération c'est un monde qui est un peu
loin nous on dans ici on travaille
beaucoup avec le district et la Ligue
qui nous aide exemple ce soir on a une
dotation on est super content d'avoir
une dotation de matériel qui représente
à peu près 500 € de de matériel qui va
donner par la Ligue pour le label
féminin là à à nos moi je demanderaiis
juste à nos instances s'il veulent nous
nous aider à tous les clubs c'est
financièrement il y a il y a deux il y a
une chose qui qui qui qui peut être fait
c'est le prix de la licence qu'on paye à
la Ligue si une licence on dire entre
parenthèses gratuite mais c'est une
bouffée d'oxygène importante pour les
clubs et après faire un statut du
bdvol parce que on parle je pense que
Mustapha son trésorier il passe
peut-être plus de temps chez lui au club
que peut-être avec sa sa famille sur
distribant sa vie de famille donc si ce
gars un jour un coup de B un coup de MO
bien voilà un statut qui passe
par déduire plus bon c'est le cas
actuellement mais peut-être vraiment se
laner là-dessus à la féé de nous aider
de parce que Mustapha raison l'argent
reste en haut il restera d'une manière
ou une autre toujours en haut alors on
peut on a bien compris he c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué de de de souten d'avoir
des partenaires qui soutiennent beaucoup
les clubs mais en ce moment on peut pas
parler de football sans parler de la
actualité brûlante qui qui remue presque
tout le football français depuis
quelques jours résult Trapp les
résultats de trappe déjà pour commencer
en tout cas le football ylinois mais il
y a aussi une grande équipe qui marche
plutôt mal on va dire depuis depuis
vendredi et qui qui fait qui suscite les
critiques c'est l'équipe de France je
vous propose d'écouter les réactions
puis les les avis des C antinois on est
allé leur poser la question avant ce
match retour face à l'Ukraine euh bah je
dirais bonne chance essayez de prendre
votre revanche parce que c'était c'était
assez dur donc voilà j'espère que vous
allez gagner et puis vive la France
j'espère qu'ils vont gagner vous y
croyez un petit peu ouais ils ont du
talent donc je pense qu'il peuvent
gagner ah la France va passer c'est sûr
moi je dis fa qu'il se bouge les fesses
un peu parce que on sait qu'ils vont
passer moi j'ai confiance mais faut
qu'il se bouge les fesses parce que là
il y a 2 quand même ben écoutez je
regarde pas énormément le foot mais bon
bon courage à eux parce qu'on espère
quand même qu'ils vont le faire pour les
championnat du
monde ils ont marqué de buts mais c'est
là c'est pas c'est pas un miracle on
peut marquer trois buts facilement avec
notre l'effectif qu'on a avec le
l'attaque qu'on a c'est c'est prenable
je leur dis du courage bon voilà je sais
que ça va pas être facile mais je pense
qu'ils ont les potentialités à voilà à
faire le la différence quoi donc je lu
dit voilà du courageant
et revenez revenez
victorieux alors messieurs vous croyez
encore à la la qualification pour
l'équipe de France là demain soir est-ce
qu'ils peuvent renverser l'Ukraine non
seulement j'y crois mais j'y serai donc
il y aura il y aura un 12e homme il y
aura le public on y sera on poussera je
crois que 2-0 c'est à la portée de
l'équipe de France l'équipe de France
saura à mon avis marqué sauf que
l'Ukraine s défendre donc la complexité
va être entre la balance entre
effectivement le fait de savoir si la
France va pouvoir marquer ces deux buts
qui pourra l'emmener en prolongation
pour le 3e simplement Ukraine ne prend
pas de but non plus donc meilleure
défense de la zone euro VO donc donc
l'Ukraine ne prend pas de but la France
devant en marqué deux pour au moins
avoir la chance de continuer d'aller
chercher le 3isème voir d'aller au
penalty ma crainte elle est là en fait
c'est les deux buts que j'imagine
facilement ma crainte ça serait qu'on
aille beaucoup plus loin dans le match
et que toute cette pression médiatique
et puis l'enjeu parce que qu' y a un
vrai enjeu puisse peser soit sur les
prolongations un pronostic alors du coup
Mustapha un petit pronostic on essaye
après ça sera au Philippe alors ça sera
pas un pronostic ça sera ça sera un
ouais 3-0 3-0 Philippe oui je pense
qu'il faut y croire ils sont mis en
difficulté mais bon pronostic comme ça m
une victoire française oui oui il faut
l'espérer qualification et une
qualification oui au bout oui et Montini
Philippe bah est-ce que est-ce qu'il
mérite d'y aller on là est la question
mais pour nous parce qu'on sait très
bien que un un bon une qualification une
participation à la Coupe du monde avec
après avec avec un bon parcours parce
qu'après tout est possible ça nous
ramène ça nous ramène bah qualification
obligatoire de l'équipe de France et ils
vont peut-être avoir une recrue
supplémentaire dont on n pas parlé c'est
un célèbre humoriste on l'a rencontré il
y a quelques jours il était là pour
l'avant-première de son dernier film La
Marche regardez je va je vais à Claire
Fontaine là pour leur remonter le moral
je vais essayer de le proposer mes
services je vais être obligé de remettre
les grolles je va je je vais voir ce que
je peux faire je vous promets rien je
rentre contre l'Ukraine à la deuxième
mi-temps ça reste contre nous
Jamel de bous peut-être le futur numéro
10 de l'équipe de France demain soir
revenons plus sérieusement juste pour
finir en un mot on va parler un peu de
vos résultats respectif attrape si il va
y avoir sûrement des matchs à r jeu
comme ça cette saison notamment face à
nanter bientôt pour l'équipe première on
parle de monter cette saison très
clairement on parle clairement de monter
on est sur le podium sur les trois
équipes l'équipe A est 2e l'équipe B est
3e l'équipe C est 3e donc oui on va pas
se mentir on n'est pas on n'est pas 2e
l'équipe n'est pas 2e pour pour essayer
de passer à côté de cette occasion mais
c'est 10 ans de boulot c'est pas ce
résultat là qui m'intéresse c'est la
résultante de tout un travail de toute
une équipe très bien merci beaucoup
messieurs d'être passé sur le 78 sport
et puis on va suivre toute l'évolution
de vos saisons respectives comme
d'habitude à très bientôt sur les
terrains merci
beaucoup en basket la 8e journée de
Nationale une féminine était le théâtre
ce weekend du derby francilien entre
Franconville et l'entente le chaîn et
Versailles un match entre de monde d'un
côté le LCV se bat pour le maintien et
de l'autre Franconville leader de la
pool vise la montée
dans ce derby francilien les féminines
de l'Entente le chîn et Versailles
pourront regretter longtemps leur entame
de match complètement raté avec un 3/ 13
au tir lors du premier Cartan les
ivelinoises n'ont jamais réussi à
revenir il nous a manqué du rythme de la
rapidité de la précision dans ce qu'on a
fait par rapport au passes à ce niveaul
ça se joue à des petits détail l'adresse
on loupe des petits paniers dessous et
puis voilà après l'écart il se C
rapidement surtout quand a éipe qui est
première du championnat pour l'instant
cette LCV Franconville était aussi le
match des retrouvailles avec trois
anciennes joueuses valdoisiennes sur le
parquet l'équipe de Stéphane Roly
ressentait comme un sentiment familier
dominé en taille et en agressivité les
coéquipières de Virginie ainant ont
parfois manqué de lucidité mais après
trois quart temps elle garde les
valdoisiennes à porté de shoot 35
44 et puis comme souvent cette saison
les ivelinoises craquent dans le dernier
cartant pour finalement s'incliner so 65
à 44 il y avait un monde d'écart entre
le leader Franconville et des
versaillaises qui découvrent pour la
plupart le haut niveau amateur une très
belle équipe de franonville qui à mon
avis terminera dans les trois premières
sans aucun souci après sont armé nous on
n pas à ce niveaau-là on a fait ce qu'on
a pu sur TR quartons 35 minutes on
craque à la fin les voix points sont
lourds mais bon c'est comme ça le LCV
pointe désormais à la 10e place et va
devoir vite oublier sa 5e défaite de la
saison pour aller s'imposer dans un duel
de mal classé à la carnache ce
weekend après le football place au
cyclisme et à un peu moins de 2 mois de
l'ouverture du vélodrome de 5anton
ilvine qu'on suit évidemment sur TVfil
et ben le club de Montini a renoué avec
la compétition le VCMB est présent ce
soir sur le 78 sport en force si j'ose
dire à ma à ma droite Daniel gagne vous
êtes le secrétaire de la nouvelle
section compétition du Vélo Club de
montinil bretonux vous êtes accompagné
du président de la section Valérie Bécu
et d'Alain léiller le président du
cyclotourisme à Montini bonsoir à tous
les trois bons alors on s'est rencontré
il y a quelques jours he pour pour cette
petite conférence de presse que vous
avez
organiser le le am Montini la vous
renouez clairement avec la compétition à
l'approche de l'ouverture du Vélodrome
c'est un peu ça Valérie tout à fait tout
à fait le Vélodrome a été le déclencheur
mais les section VTT actuelle qui sont
les renards du Manet et le la section
cyclo du VCMB a souhaité se doter d'un
pôle compétition dédié pourquoi ça
manquait cruellement au club où il y
avait un souhait peut-être aussi
d'adhérent Daniel ah tout à fait tout à
fait disons que le le problème c'est que
jusqu'à maintenant les jeunes il y avait
une école de VTT et derrière il y avait
rien voilà donc quand il voulait aller
faire la compétition ben il falludait
qu'il parte ailleurs c'était en quelque
sorte une formation un peu inachevée on
peut dire ça il manquait quelque chose à
la fin du cycle tout à fait c'est c'est
vraiment ça il y avait il y avait
vraiment une un manque de ce côté-là
alors les jeunes faisaient de la
compétition mais ça restait quand même
une ça restait l'initiative des familles
uniquement donc sans encadrement
spécifique du club voilà mais alors
pourquoi avoir délaissé la la section où
le pan compétition Alain pendant
peut-être tant d'années mais
c'est-à-dire que précédemment la section
Sion compétition qui existait au vélo
club était une section qui était en fait
juste apposée aux deux autres sections
et avec des gens qui souhaitaient faire
la de la de la comption faire une école
de cycliste avec des jeunes mais il
manquait cruellement d'encadrement parce
que c'étaai des gens qui venaient de
l'extérieur qui s'étaient implantés à de
Montigny et qui qui ne s'étaient pas
intégré dans les deux autres sections là
B les deux sections VTT et cyclotourisme
représentent une force de frappe
importante puisque nous sommes 250 au
adhérents au cyclotourisme 227 je crois
à la section
VTT ce qui fait du vélo club de montigy
le plus grand club d'île-de France et
effectivement ce qui fait la la le
démarrage de cette comme le disait
Daniel ça manquéit cruellement
l'existence d'une section compé parce
que parmi les deux sections il y avait
des jeunes qui qui pour un jeune la
compétition est une suite
normale de la pratique cycliste
et donc le ce qu'il c'est une c'est les
dirigeens des deux sections qui se sont
investis pour créer cette section
compétition mais dans dans ce secteur là
de la compétition vous allez avoir une
forte concurrence si j'ose dire puisque
il y a le Vélo Club des lancours de scat
Evelin qui a aussi sa section
compétition donc du coup de club si
proche géographiquement vont vont être
concurrents directement non ça c'est
prant en
cyclo il y a deux clubs importants il y
a morpa et nous alors je vois pas
pourquoi ce sera pas la même chose en
compétition et qu'est-ce que vous
attendez de l'ouverture du Vélodrome à
Montini des créneaux de piste peut-être
une bouffée
d'oxygène non je enfin moi
personnellement les créau de piste bah
ça viendra pour nous comme pour tous les
autres clubs de l'Île-de-France euh
simplement euh que on arrive je dirais à
redynamiser euh le cyclisme de
compétition sur le 78 parce qu'il faut
savoir que aujourd'hui le
78 bah c'est un peu le parent- pauvre du
comité de l'Île-de-France j'ai regardé
les classements
euh des des finales du comité de
l'île-de-fance à mon Eré du mois de
septembre sur route il y a pas y a il y
a pas un coureur du 78 dans le
classement donc l'objectif sera ça
d'essayer de remotiver et de redonner de
l'élan à la compétition l'objectif il
est de faire de faire de la section
compétition du
VCMB à 4 ans une échéance raisonnable le
premier club compétition du 78 on prend
rendez-vous on se RRA dans 4 ans et puis
on on verra si si l'objectif sera
atteint on on se reverra avant oui avant
bien sûr évidemment on reverra avant
mais pour pour cet objectif là en tout
cas à moyen terme il y a pas de souci
très bien merci beaucoup à tous les
trois d'être passé sur le C H sport et
puis on se revoit bientôt près du
Vélodrome j'imagine bien sûr bien sûr
merci beaucoup merci lors de cette
saison 2013 Alan Brachet a écrit l'une
des plus belles pages de l'histoire du
triathlon français à 15 ans ce jeune
triathlète de 50 ans en yeline est
devenu le premier champion de France de
triathlon de duathlon d'aquathlon mais
également champion du monde scolaire de
triathlon rencontre avec la nouvelle
pépite de la
discipline généralement le triathlon
n'est pas le sport qui vient
naturellement à la bouche des enfants
c'est en voyant son père s'entraîner
qu'Alan Brachet a voulu suivre ses trace
il le lance tout d'abord dans la
natation avec les bébés nageur et dè
qu'Al pu y participer il s'est aligné
sur l'épreuve à seulement 7 ans sur les
premières compétitions en natation quand
il était tout petit quand il était
avenir il gagnait déjà donc les autres
voy Alan comme un extraterrestre pourant
il était pas grand il était pas super
grand par rapport au autres pour prière
n'a pas gagné en quelque sorte
l'exception qui confirme la règle car 8
ans plus tard Alan a accompli le grand
schlem champion de France minime de
triathlon de duathlon et d'aquathlon il
a également régné sur les championnats
du monde scolaire à Porto Rico une
performance inédite dans l'histoire du
tri français qui ne semble pas rassasier
le jeune colosse bien au contraire au
fur à mesure des compè des compétitions
du coup bah j'ai la sensation de nager
plus vite ou de rouler plus vite pour
certaines ou même certaines courir
encore plus vite enin c'est la sensation
que ça me procure et bah ça me plaît de
plus en plus avec ces sensations là en
fait c'est positivement incroyable c'est
quelque chose qui n'a jamais été fait
quand quelque chose qui n'a jamais été
fait arrive tout le monde est surpris on
se dit il va pas y arriver si Alan y
arrive donc c'est c'est ce qui est le
plus surprenant c'est ce qui est
étonnant chez lui et il fait ça avec une
déconstraction déconcertante il fait ça
naturellement il va pas au-delà on a on
lui a pas demandé d'aller adelà de ses
performances il a pas il s'est pas
entraîné plus que d'habitude son avenir
sur les podiums dépendra de sa course à
pied pour l'instant la machine survole
la natation et le vélo mais il doit
encore progresser dans la 3è épreuve
malgré une pointe de vitesse moyenne de
18 km he par rapport au niveau mondial
les meilleurs je sais je suis encore
très loin d'eux et bah du coup j'essaie
de vraiment me rapprocher pour ensuiteah
plus tard les B donc l'objectif c'est
plus tard d'être au et de pouvoir faire
une grande possibilité de médaille quoi
cette nouvelle saison va déjà être
révélatrice pour Alan Brachet passant
chez les cadets les distances de course
vont doubler le chemin est encore long
pour le nouveau diamant du tri
français en rugby c'était le choc de
cette 8e journée de fédéral 3 plaisir 2e
se déplaçait chez le leader a vaincu
Orléan les joueurs de Philippe Béard
trop indicip incliné avec SEP pénalités
concédés sont passés tout près de
l'exploit mais s'incline finalement de
deux petits points 28 26 et gagne un
précieux point de bonus défensif
9e journée de Division 2 en football
féminin Montini dernier recevit rouvroi
10e nouvelle défaite pour les in
montaines 3-0 3e défaite consécutive
pour les joueuses de jeanani Grosset en
basket 8e journée de National 3 homme
après deux matchs sans victoire trappe
c'est bien repris en s'imposant à
domicile face au dernier wasel 69 à 53
et nouvelle défaite pour le CV de son
côté AG gravanchon 82 à 68 les trapistes
remontent 6e et les Versaillais stagnent
à la 9e place en voile on suit
évidemment Tangui de la mode vous vous
souvenez sur le vent des globes notre
navigateur versaillais a pris le départ
au Havre de la 11e transat jackes Vabre
à bord d'initiative cœur cette course
s'effectue en duo et Tanguy a recruté un
partenaire plutôt original en la
personne de François Damiens il navigue
direction itajil au Brésil à plus de
5000 km dans leur catégorie il pointe
actuellement la 10e place à plus de
570000 du leader massif de François
Gabard et Michel desjoyau he je vous
rappelle Tangui de la mode court pour
une opération caritative permettre à des
enfants de de se faire opérer du cœur il
a déjà sauvé trois enfants enfin une
dernière info c'est du vélo on en parlé
tout à l'heure note cette date le 31
janvier 2014 cet homme s'appelle Robert
Marchand il a 102 ans et le détenteur du
record du monde de l'heure de la
catégorie plus de 100 ans il tentera
évidemment de battre son record cette
datelà en 2014 au record établi en
février
2012 c'est la fin de ce 78 sport merci
de l'avoir suivi n'hésitez pas à le
commenter hein sur Twitter avec le
hashtag le 78 sport tout attaché on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine lundi même
heure même
lieu